[Music]
just
protect your center
[Music]
so
a key
point you want to get
uh
with all the various
uh administrative starting points in
your keyhole so you have
there's many reasons but i would say the
most important one if you're after
a spontaneous expression of the arts if
you are after takamusai which all of you
are here
for that reason
you have to find what is common
between the two
that i just gave you for example okay
uh you know if you do contact and your
technique goes one way and then you use
your head it looks another way then
you're not succeeding in that cool
okay
um
but it's not just these two
administrative starting points it would
be all of the administrative starting
points okay and then all the ones that
are not given
um and what is common to them is you go
i got the front end kazushi whatever
he's touching
um
i work with that or he's touching me i
establish my ground vectors my cocky
projection my eye kit adhesions
and then
i keep my uh
front inward kazushi pattern and my
spiraling geometry rotating across and
now the technique looks exactly the same
okay
uh so what's key here is that
it's the same
angle of deviation
whether he's holding his hand or not
that doesn't have to change
um
same thing
i go over this way
that's the energy that hits the ground
that's the one i take back into him into
the front
inward
but he's touching the other hand
so it's not that i ignore the other hand
and it's just there
and then i go here
because now
while consistent between
and tata is not consistent
with all the other techniques
ekyo and kokunagi
now i need to find that same singularity
so if he's touching that hand
and i need to get
the front inward position
is this one
[Music]
don't let it go
dead i'm gonna use it
and when he falls off of it then it goes
back into the
so i'm using it
it's not dead
i'm using it
uh
[Music]
don't grab them just
do cookie on the other arm
don't grab them with that left arm go
[Music]
speed up that entry that pause is not
marshall which rolls
outside find outside that other arm
outside like coquiho
like tokyo
come over the top go
outside there you go
keep going
good
enter speed up that entry got to get rid
of that cap
you're bracing on the mat that's how you
get hurt
don't pull the wrist off that's not
marshall
no you're pulling the wrist off
[Music]
keep your grip strong
push through to the elbow push through
the elbow
that's the form it's been said a million
times
push through to the elbow you did it
again
keep going
just hold your hand on his wrist till
you push through it comes off
push push okay anyone can do it slow we
don't care about slow
push there you go
be ready to catch it
there you go
okay so uh
if
the mistake you're making
you're going here
and then you're pulling it off
um or the pause mistake that you're
making just you can watch more
in this pause right here this leg is
going to come in his legs
um
reverse what mistakes are being made
before that and you're going to see that
you're violating yin and yang
reconciliation
so
he's here
and you're pushing
there okay
which means you're
you're starting your entry
uh before he's done coming at you
okay
so the reverse the equal opposite energy
is
stopping you
you either have to wait till enough of
it comes off
or you have to i'm trying to get it out
of the way
now
so if we go to uh
just katakta so you could see it
it's he's charging we have yoyo here
he's charging it and that's what i used
to send him flying okay
uh
so when i actually
give me some energy
boom when i actually enter he he's going
that way
i don't enter
to make him go
that way
that's a yangyang clash i can only enter
where there's in space okay
so
when i go
boom i'm following the elbow
that's going that way
i'm not pushing the
elbow therefore i can get to the elbow
so he hits one of
the elbows
in
therefore
i don't need to get the hand out of the
way
we've done this a million times but you
can see
push almost pushing on me
[Music]
that's the
will to power that's a fear response
it's not aikido it's not jiu-jitsu okay
you'll have to obey it and yawn
so you can only enter
where there's a cavity for you to enter
you cannot push through okay that's not
the art you can if you're strong enough
you can do it it'll work
but not the art okay
it's a much lower performance ceiling on
that working
so
we're just going to micro drill
to the elbow
got it
so boom
pop
in
try to try to see how it goes here
boom
that's when i feel that that's when i
enter
boom
you can see how the grip is being
dismantled here's not at all dismantled
but by moving in
when he's already gone that way
you're
passing through
their
in the technique your hand is just there
it's not ripping it off
it's just there
to catch it
it's jumping into your other hand but
we're going to take that second hand out
and just find the elbow